hello everyone hope you wells I'm not
gonna lie I didn't have the best day in
the world yesterday so instead of making
the video that I had planned to make
today the one that took me like three
days to write so I'm just gonna look
through this jam jar this was given to
me last time I was in Canada I I have no
idea because you didn't write your name
anywhere on here so who are you but
basically what it is is it's 50 reasons
to love charlie is so cool like it says
if you ever need a pick-me-up or are
ever curious as to what's inside open up
for a metaphorical hug from your fans
that sounds lovely to me okay here we go
even though you are halfway across the
world we still feel close to you oh
that's lovely we love the way you sing
guacamole I do say it kind of funny
don't like guacamole
spit moly we all love your challenge
Charlie's sorry I ever done one in ages
I should try and figure out another way
to do one it's just like challenges on
YouTube kind of been ruined for me now
I'll have a think I'll see what I can do
for you you have a cute booty do I have
a cute booty have I even shown my booty
to you we'll just give you a hint
hold on there we go pretty cute eh
pretty cute pretty adorable
I wasn't expecting to do that in this
video gotta be honest when you wear
glasses it gives us chest pains how is
that a good thing I assume chest pains
must mean like like swooning to the the
point where like your chest is kind of
hurting I don't know I feel like I
should take my glasses off now I think
I'm gonna do that no I need to see I'm
sorry your channel isn't only comedic
it's also informational have I
disseminated any information today
what can I do I'll give you a tip banana
is a great source of potassium there we
go comedy and information that's me we
love tea just as much as you do
do you though do you have 10 different
types of tea and you covered four
different times a day do you have your
own special blend of tea made just for
you maybe you do god I'm gonna stop
making tea such an important part of my
personality oh my god we love your
dancing skills you know it doesn't love
my dancing skills my cats
whenever I try and dance in his
direction which is quite often he finds
it well you used to find it like so
terrifying that he would run off into
the corner nowadays he will just sort of
like glare at me uncomfortably one day
he will love it though you will love it
as much as you do I'm sorry you're
amazing as a giant teabag I really wish
I still had that costume I threw it away
after we were done making that film
because I was like you know where am I
gonna keep a giant teabag
well you
we're gonna have this I know the use now
if I had that around I just you know put
it on and just feel feel better because
I sounds quite weird isn't it maybe it's
better I got rid of it your songs give
us life wow that's a big compliment now
I'm just feeling really bad about the
fact they haven't written a song in like
two years yet another thing that I now
feel like I have to do your smile
brightens up our day I don't even want
to think of funny things to say anymore
just having a really nice time you make
a smile I can make you smile that's good
be a bit of a shame you for you're just
sitting there frowning this whole time
wouldn't it oh good well I kind of want
to cry now
I'm hoarding in thank you so much for
the person who made that for me or
people I don't even know I want to meet
you so I can like buy you a cake or
something because that was just that was
just so lovely I'm in such an amazingly
lucky position where if I can feel down
I can know that there are people out
there in the world who want to help me
want to make me feel better and so I
hope I can still do that for you as well
see you next time goodbye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool